this is the second day of the planner
would a conference and is the second or
third the workshop third right so many I
can keep track exactly so I'm in about
three this is a somewhat ad hoc one that
that we've organized Rob skiff and I
have been having a lot of discussions
back and forth about the nature of a
player now in relation to agency
capitalism you know values all the sort
of big picture sticky kinds of things
that people could get a very concerned
about so this is a chance for viewers to
write in and ask questions wherever you
have a set of them but we wanted to also
lay out you know some of the things that
keep coming up over and over again how
think with a clear no it's easy to get
mixed up about this because they're
doing something quite different than
most other educational institutions have
been doing so well I was going to be
doing most of the talking during this
I'm going to reject every once in a
while I've got a set of questions why
don't we begin by you till acting a
little bit about the model of paranoia
and what were the four big problems that
Clara was supposed to to address so uh
when I was a doctoral student and I
still AM and I'm finishing my
dissertation ah the things that I wrote
about were student loan on financing and
the student loan bubble I'm in the
United States most of the education is
most of horrendous financed through
subsidized loans or on subsidized loans
and government programs for students
take out debt to pay for their
undergraduate or graduate Amanda um it's
ginormous and depending on where you go
to school it's you know really huge and
so the debt piece arm you know now I
think it's 1.2 trillion it's actually
there's more student loan debt than
there is credit card debt yeah it's a
huge on risk to the financial markets
and if you'd risk actually to people
because if you're a student
you have lots of debt then you can't arm
start your own business you are going to
have a harder time becoming involved in
social entrepreneur ship you know a hard
time getting involved or finding
something that can pay in terms of you
know if you want to get into service
with helping industries I got really
handicapped you in a lot of ways yeah um
and prevents you from starting to
accumulate some wealth and resources new
year old in your four year old age yeah
and so that is combined so the super
loan debt had me concerned but another
piece was on part of the work that I did
to pay for my doctoral program I mean I
was lucky that I got um some money from
the University of Vermont and they were
very helpful in terms of supporting me
um but I also worked as an adjunct and
huge usha um as an adjunct what i would
do is i get assigned roughly you know
two or three weeks or sometimes two days
before the semester started and i would
be given this class that was generally
you know this was online sometimes in
person and the class would kind of not
be very well built and so I'd spent all
this time changing the class or adding
different things to it and um at the end
of the semester I've put in all this
work reading this really great class and
of course I didn't own it and I you know
sometimes I wouldn't get the same class
the next semester yeah and you know that
was just kind of like unfair or I you
know oh my I do a lot of work I also
rescue the institution okay in some ways
I provide the students with the great
experience and I don't own the class
that I teaching yeah and the next thing
that really struck me is you know I was
getting paid you know three grand I'll
three grand for the class of an eye to
the calculus on how many people I was
teaching what I was getting paid and I
said Wow somebody's making a lot of
money it ain't me yeah um and so that
kind of
then as I'm going through my doctoral
program I'm looking around for a sort of
a tenure-track job and I do a little
business analysis of you know what's the
stability of me what's the chances of me
getting a tenure-track job and next if
the institution what's the odds of the
institution that I'm going to join is
actually going to survive in the same
form over the next ten years yeah okay
and what I found out was um one the
business model is is really kind of
broken for most traditional Xin hire a
what i mean by business model i'm not
talking about I'm talking about two
things I'm talking about social capital
financial capital and cultural capital
okay generating all three of those
pieces um I'm not talking about making
you know just you know making money okay
but if you want to do a Marxist
interpretation okay who owns the means
of production okay and um who is
benefiting from the means of production
and what I and and what I had a kinda
thought the students that's for sure
well i kind of said the people who are
benefiting a kind of the bondholders
okay the people who are holding the
majority of the student debt then I
started to look at I'm actually on the
number of students taught and the amount
of pay the people were receding and I
realized after looking at a couple
different schools that the number of
students that did a professor
encountered was inversely proportional
to the amount of money they were making
so the more students you've taught the
less money you make any sense and um and
I also looked around at my department
and looked around at the University
where I was at and I realized that the
people who were getting paid the lease
were generally um were women who are in
tenure track positions I'm not sorry
they weren't in tenure track positions
they were at Johnson's yeah and they
even though they were if you did a
strict economic analysis they were
giving from they were returning
tremendous amounts of capital
to their institution they constantly
felt as if they might get canned they
might not be let let might not be given
the next job so um you know and end up
being blunt um I needed to find a job
and was rapidly realizing that that I
was unemployable in the in traditional I
read on for a variety of different
reasons which has probably become quite
apparent as we have done done na would
lock on and those are two big issues to
help adjuncts to others that you wanted
to write the other pieces on the lack of
arm you know countable well the one is
the technology piece okay um
disintermediation is the well let's
start with disintermediation first tell
them what that fancy through okay
disintermediation means sort of like
cutting out the middleman yeah or middle
person um instead of trying to get
people when they're exchanging something
to cut out the person who's acting is
the intermediary okay the gay person
between the gatekeeper and that DOM and
disintermediation is you know
eliminating barriers to people
exchanging things now the
disintermediation hold up I guess what
I'm going to do is I'm going to hit the
will get to the Twitter comments in a
second when you do those are the little
bit later okay um one of the things with
the disintermediation one of the things
this technology is is creating a lot of
it's creating a lot of changes we all
know that's you know everybody knows
that but what it's what it's really
doing is its stressing out traditional
institutions there's so much information
and change it is happening at two
institutions today you have the
traditional command and control
structure doesn't really work okay
that's not agile um at all it worked a
hundred years ago or two hundred years
but it doesn't work anymore especially
you know let's talk about degree program
formation okay if you want to it takes
years for a new degree to be introduced
to a university sometimes yeah um and by
the time the degree is introduced maybe
the market demand is gone yeah the
disciplines completely change so the so
technology um also allows the
elimination of dependencies of time and
place for where education occurs so it
changes access so yeah so that's the
fourth thing young access um the we can
learn the technology now with video
teleconferencing with the database with
the data storage and the fact that it's
really cheap on you can store video text
audio anywhere you can upload it the
fact that it is so cheap to do that and
the fact that the video teleconferencing
is so good that you can have that small
we're gonna do the student we can do
this um we can have small groups of you
know a group of faculty working with
students from all over the world and it
can be what I think is the best in
education which is kind of the Socratic
you can work on projects together you
have conversations you can build
knowledge you can you can actually if
you have a you're working with a
particular community the community can
decide on what issues it wants to solve
and seek out the experts and the
knowledge to solve those particular
pieces and it's all accessible on you
know on a smartphone yeah and in
traditional hi reddit is still very much
dependent upon people coming to the
location okay and and coming to a
particular point in time in a day and
all sitting in the classroom and
spending two hours either hearing a
lecture or or engaging in a discussion
even with online stuff you know for
instance I I teach online for an
institution traditional institution that
has enough foresight to realize that you
should do some online classes I have
people you know wine exact how can I get
in your class you know you're teaching
an ethics class I'd really like
well you'd have to sign up with this
university you'd have to sign up with
this college you would have to
matriculate you would have to do all
these things that you know would be
required in order for them to get into
my my class and then in part because I'm
an adjunct I may not be teaching that
class right you know it may have gotten
farmed out to one of the full timers who
preferred you know he wanted to teach
that class this summer or you know maybe
they decide of the not going to do that
class so there's no guarantee that
you'll actually get it so that how is it
was a rosa i also adore no hassel Erin
out Chad stats very funny yeah I was a
player no address thank you why did that
lead you to wanna do well the UM the
biggest issue is access ok so we've hit
a capacity issue in globally in terms of
high red when it's dependent so much on
the traditional models of delivery which
are centered around physical classroom
spaces we have a location with a surplus
of people who actually could teach who
can't get jobs in these slots accept it
you know some sentence wages we have a
ton of students some of whom can't kick
it in we're letting them in by getting
them huge debts well I mean there are
you know we've hit it if we measure
social progress by you know financial
just what people are making it's a
disaster yeah if we measure if we
measure the waste of talent out there
because number one a person can't get
access to a good education good
instruction or we measure the waist of
people who can't who are great and who
can't teach access is huge is a huge
traditional higher end being so
dependent on the brick and mortar and
and so still so dependent upon you know
up la III to a particular school there's
a certain number of slots down I mean
seven billion people on the planet on
endl up auto p
that vacation and will not reproduce the
skin and afford to eat those needs of
really when you think about it still the
people who have access to higher
education the best kind of teaching the
number 10 and we really need to make it
so that part of sort of the that we not
only think of is financially but we
think it's culturally and socially the
better educated of population is and
especially the in terms of the
individual deciding what they want to
learn it in person in particular culture
yeah area wanting to learn the better
off we all are because they can maximize
their potential now isn't that if I mean
that's kind of supposed to be what so
good as a ms about so this is a good
segue into tackling one of the big
questions that has come up you know
you've got something called a
marketplace for for classes and some
people are worried that this is this is
a capitalist model therefore its market
forces that are going to be deciding
what's going on how are you any
different say than some of the other you
know for the big for profits out there
that are getting a you know scrutinize
for taking you know student loans up and
not returning on the investment so you
know what do you have to say about that
um capital is running on capitalist
running dog than I am I'm in the tie
living in New England um so one of the
things that has happened in the last ten
years and and the breakdown and command
and control management techniques and
those hierarchies and the fact that they
don't work they're not adaptable is that
um that they haven't been replaced by
anything that is grassroots and
self-organizing yeah okay now arm one of
the ways in which you self-organized is
you allow people to exchange between you
allow people to exchange services
exchange knowledge exchange whatever arm
in a very transparent and open system
where there are where there's um as much
discovery and transparency as possible
okay now what that does is that it kind
of weeds out it allows dit it weeds out
is probably not the right term e it's
much more efficient than for the end and
as much making can create a decision
you're going to do with this you're
going to do it this way or here's my
group of so-called experts from the top
Ivy League schools or wherever and and
they're going to decide on this is what
we eat over the next 10 years so when we
become a society because of the
information and the the explosion of
information in the explosion of change
we've really become a command and
control society in a lot of aspects in
other words we have a small group of
people who are SI making the decisions
for large numbers of individuals so am i
a capitalist running dog I'm not in the
out opposite meaning that you know
trying to use resistance for me in that
heart and negri you know what the the
sense of resisting some of the hegemonic
moves is about empowering the individual
and about creating agency and if you're
going to create agency you have to have
choice and you have to allow people to
choose for themselves the routes they're
going to take and you also have to make
it completely transparent about what is
your cut yeah okay so I can't eliminate
I'm trying to eliminate as many of the
do as much disintermediation in
education as possible okay yeah I'm
trying to place the the capital the the
reward for the work and for the great
teaching back in the hands of the
faculty but I'm also trying to help the
students okay fine maximize their
choices to find the mentors and the
classes and the skills that are best
going to meet their needs so you know we
have on our business structure you know
we're in LLC a privately held company
now why are we a privately held company
versus a not-for-profit um I have a
really strong vision of where I want to
take this in terms of the the equality
and the disintermediation and the value
that I feel a faculty and students and
cutting out a lot of the the middle the
middle man if I were a not-for-profit if
a plural is a not-for-profit we would
have a board and I would be answerable
to the board it was a lot of time to get
anything done yeah well I think he'd
also um a lot enough for profits will
lose their vision and and they also
become if they're successful they also
become sort of subverted by their own
success yeah so right now onward an LLC
we may transition to another type of
governance system but I need to be able
to in our team needs to be able to feel
secure that our vision that we're not
going to compromise on our future yeah
and um we're also you know we have an
accepted venture capitalist money ok
because and we're doing this on through
some self funding and a lot of you know
because change for labor the IndieGoGo
piece the fact that you know Daniel and
Dan on a part of a player no um and
along with you know the board of
directors and some few other people um
but we're not gonna I control the vast
majority and I'm not going to sell we're
not interested in building up a planner
and flipping it to Google and making a
billion dollars or yeah or Yahoo or
Apple or GE or you know we're not
interested in that we've got to be
interested um I'm interested in making
sure that education is affordable and
I'd much rather spend my time on making
sure that adjuncts get a decent pay and
and we're able to do something really
cool with education because to be honest
I mean like what else is there to spend
this is I mean it sounds naive but what
else is there expand your time on um you
know I live in Vermont it's a great
great place i have three squares on
you're staying at my house no it's not
extravagant it's a nice house what i
mean like i don't need the Gulf Stream
five or the or the Ferrari and that's
not what this is about I think something
when people bring up capitalism one
thing that they they lose sight of is
that capitalism first of all we will do
whether it's understood
bad that's a separate question but you
can tell all exchange automatically
capitals just simply because there's
exchange simply because there's some
sort of you know structure what money is
changing hands for services that happens
in it you know in all different types of
economies and then you know the other
thing to keep in mind is when we're
worried about some of the bad parts like
apples it's usually because of outside
forces that don't respect the values
coming in and you know leveraging
somehow what's going on over here where
there is some sort of value and making
it do something different so you know
for example if you if you develop a
really good company that's doing
something good and then google buys you
I don't mind you know that Google you
know they're there don't be evil I think
they do sometimes you know here but even
though you know so their technology do
you think this it's when something is
coming in from the outside and removing
agency and so we'll talk more money well
then I mean capitalism crony capitalism
is incredibly bad yes and lack of
transparent markets and lack of well
lack of transparency and exploitative
relationship is batting and well the
u.s. is full of that I mean you know one
yeah full of that right now so it's
funny because in some chats and with
some groups that I'll go that I talked
to I either get a cute I either get hit
with you are I mean you're a capitalist
you're doing God how can you bring
capitalism into education where then I
go into another group and your Lamar and
and I am you know the the yeah the
Marxist anarchist piece because I'm
saying things like well you know crony
capitalism is not okay yeah secrecy and
democracy do not are not do not go in
and Rob and I are coming from different
perspectives on this finding common
ground in part I'm much more you know
neo resilient influenced by the
Tocqueville so I you could say I'm more
conservative
back then then Ron but I don't actually
fit in on today's conservativism but I
am interested because of these these
thinkers yeah these issues an agency and
how students can actually take some
control their own destiny how professors
can actually be put back into you know
the center of the the educational
enterprise because really it comes out
it what is education students and
professors and everybody else's it's
because they're a support deaf you know
not to to run the show but what's
interesting about this is this is this
is not offering some sort of mobile
solution that you know will become the
new answer to everything but it is
offering you know a response to a really
deeply problematic situation having to
do with education and people who think
seriously about this from a variety of
perspectives can get behind Rob and I
don't agree on some of our basic
premises but we can arrive at some of
the same conclusions with respect to
this I think that's important I mean if
you know one of the things is you have
to create protocols yeah standards where
and you have that some principles that
you're actually going to going to live
by and one of those principles that
prevents things from becoming abusive is
again transparent yes yes because I'd
words access to information and really
access to information in this case is
price ok the real cost through a real
cost of something ok there aren't hidden
costs and where the money is going yep
anybody who you know gets gets involved
in an eclair no class and no this amount
of money is going to the professor this
amount is going to a player now once you
guys start you know doing anything else
like advising they can know exactly
where the money devoted to but it's also
going to go into the fact that um um you
know today we have lunch at skinny
pancake that's true 24 48 bucks yeah um
it's fine that's part of where that
tennis court yeah well not that we need
we need more students but you know what
it's completely appropriate for the
faculty to understand and to be able to
end the students actually to be able to
look at
senior administrators expense account
yeah and to be able to see on that skiff
went out to lunch for 48 bucks too
skinny pancake with two professors
outrageous okay well yeah because I'm
part of that I mean while we all as
people have privacy we should have
practices institutions and reserves of
alba in their roles to serve the public
good okay or will do not have so much
secrecy about the the operations because
it's the secrecy about where the money
is going that generates a huge amount of
the abuse and you know it's it's a great
i am yes bishop yeah on people as far as
well yep so um you know that's all you
know that's that's where I'm coming from
with with that piece but the agency
you've gotta maximize agency you've got
it before you know academic freedom yeah
you all have to be instead of doing
hegemonic moves to impose their
education on other people and on ended
and all that other cultures or countries
you know communities and individuals are
perfectly capable of figuring out what
they need they don't need to be told on
here's why here's the format here's the
here's the deal and you're going to be
wanting x policy once again it's choice
yeah I think Aristotle could be a
benefit to people and I want to teach
you no classes on that they're free to
say man not for us yeah I mean you know
you'd seek a check out you know check
out Aristotle but he should also have
the space to check out um wrong she um
you know marks on magar china arm
mensches matsu and you know a variety of
other dear mother is let's talk more
about developing agency because this is
one of the areas where we really have a
lot of common ground and i mentioned
that i look at these things and mr.
Killian why I'm also when it comes to
this sort of stuff very influenced by
vitac oil and the total a lot
other great things about American
democracy as opposed to European
democracy was that Americans when they
ran into a problem they would keep
things at a low level form what he
called intermediate associations and
rather than just immediately think the
state should help us out or you know in
our case it might not just be the state
it might be let's let the market decide
porn let's let me know some NGO make the
decisions for us it keeps it in the
hands of the people who are directly
affected and what the total field
thought was really important with this
and we've talked a lot about this why
this is missing in contemporary
education especially in part of the
professor's is by being involved in some
sort of governance even if it's just you
know running a clock you you start to
acquire the capacities to be able to do
it on a veteran better than we start to
be able to reflect on what's what's
actually good what should I be doing
what should I be avoiding you're given
the chance to to screw up and to make
good on that sort of thing and that
doesn't happen with the command control
thing you know we're you know what's
going to what's going to get 12 is
trickling down and coming to the
professors and maybe they get to say
well I'd like to teach a class on
ancient philosophy next semester but
it'll be taught to miss this slot with a
player know you're looking for and
hoping to cultivate professors who are
you know really just come out with it
more entrepreneurial in that way who are
willing to say yeah I'll take
responsibility for a classroom and I'm
going to put together this structure
we'll see how it works with the students
and I mean I you know the agency and
responsibility go together yeah I don't
know whether you know you know the
looking for professors who are
entrepreneurial I think that's true but
I think even more importantly is you're
looking for you're looking for
professors who are on the classics
scholar practitioners who have praxis
yeah in other words um who are out there
in the world as arm change agents
and helping other people become change
agents to because that's the I mean I
guess I think that's the tension in
education today is that in some ways you
have really disciplinary procedures and
reproductions of social class and
privilege and and institutions designed
to do that again and again and again and
yeah generation after a generation and
how much of the education actually is
about you Noah Liberatore practices
where you're where you're allowing
people to form and create their own
lives and their own communities and
their own associations without telling
them on what to do and and I think that
that right now we're kind of in that in
this state of a lot of us are sort of
battling against that prescriptive piece
and the first in the first institutions
and trying to come up with ways in which
people can retake can contain charged
with their own lives in their own agent
I think it will be a gradual process
it's one of those this is the 07
Alliance into total spine Mills point
about this sort of development of agency
it takes being involved in X or
consecutive process to augment that Emma
grow so say somebody comes in and starts
teaching for a player no they're not you
know entrepreneurial in that way it's a
space in which they can become a nun as
opposed to you know traditional
Department where that's not going to
happen yeah i mean with you know the
fact you know we need it's tough to
identify i think i know the kind of
people would be successful with the
final model i think i know i think we
got a good understanding of of you know
how are you gonna have to develop your
skills yeah to do that and you know
right now i mean the professorial has
been socialized in a particular way yeah
okay that in some ways is designed for
the for that command and control
hierarchical system and it selects
against that i mean i have a shirt i
have a friend who you know does a lot of
public speaker speaking of involvement
ethics and because he was doing it in a
popular form he essentially became
persona
crowd upon his peers yeah you know that
really really bothered I mean thank
thank God you continued because it's
important work but you know the way
things are currently set up really
selects against taking initiative yeah I
mean it except except for the ones who
are entitled so if you're going to
ideally you know design your research
curriculum teach which are going to
teach but if you're you know in the
majority of educational institutions and
not the middle and lower tier ones
that's that's just not available yeah
yeah now I'm not going to yeah there are
just so many there are so many ways in
which the the traditional system I mean
it worked for the old means of
production yeah okay it worked for the
industrial tailoress you know fortis
model okay but we're in a different era
now and there are some things that are
going to remain the same okay but there
are other types of you know to use um
you know sort of Latour this you know
French you know great French
practitioner to lose and guitari yeah he
saw these guys that I'm that I really
enjoy you talk about sort of non-human
agency and these things called
assemblages on which are basically
instead of looking at at just people
having or not having agency look at how
institutions form and shape people's
behaviors and how they have their own
tactics and strategy as a as a as a
piece of as a way of analyzing what's
going on and you know things have just
changed that the the the way in which
technology the way in which the internet
the way has changed space and time yeah
okay it hasn't gotten rid of it but it
allows different types of exchanges to
happen I mean you and I would never have
met oh yeah yeah yeah we hadn't had the
internet we were talking over the
Internet this is the first time I've
never met I have never been in the same
room hello Daniel come together through
we see each other's here I've never been
in the same room with
Daniel Crompton the art director of IT I
don't mean to yeah okay um other people
that I've you know encountered on you
know Angeles or building saw simple with
the members of the board of director
some students faculty never been in the
same room um but yet we're able to do
this work through this through the use
of this new assemblage mom which is the
you know the information technology and
that changes everything yeah one of the
things that I am particularly found
attractive about Claire not because i
was looking a lot of different types of
online education was that you know if
there's anything about which I'm
steering towards it on the Marxist it's
that I don't like these sort of prestige
hierarchies that replicate themselves
and I see that happening very much so
with the top-tier institutions and you
know technology was supposed to be
disrupted so MOOCs were going to like
disrupt everything but then you know who
got to actually run the moose it was it
was people who were pulled from you know
the Ivy League's and the big states and
a few other schools that had long
technology investment so I've used you
know this is an example before I like
might send I like his books I had a
chance to take a class with them you
know in a small setting I certainly
would but I sure don't think that his
his move ought to be replacing
instructors the way that they tried to
do in a few places it was a live
proposal yeah me and so when I see a
pharaoh doing in part we precisely is an
acting thing is this is I mean look at
me I'm practically speaking and nobody
when it comes to this room stuff I
didn't go to a prestigious graduate
school I've published but so they had a
lot of people published and I can teach
classes through this and if I do it well
then people can find out about it and
students can say hey this guy I want to
do some things with them that's way up
YouTube that wouldn't be possible
without this this sort of apparatus well
and it wouldn't even be possible with
MOOCs because
you know you're not going to get invited
to be on EDX or corsair or something
like that if you're at motor school or
military well the I guess there's two
pieces is that we can't look at even
though you have the evangelist of
technology who think of it as an
laboratory practice technology is not
deterministic yeah it doesn't in some
ways can reinforce hierarchies as we see
with you know the National Security
Agency ow ow and other other you know
nefarious government entities where the
use technology to leverage their own
networks of social political control etc
okay now however technology can also be
on liberatore if it's deployed properly
yes ok so I think that's the that's a
thing when i was on creating computer
models of i like created a computer
model of the institution i attended ok
financial wise to look at the to look at
to play with whatever the simulation
well i was keep back when I wanted to be
a you know wanted to join the crowd yeah
ok I was like oh I'll use this to find a
strategy that would allow them to deal
with this new era ok to deal with the
student debt crisis to cut their costs
well when I built the simulation and I
started playing with what is ok I came
to the conclusion that I couldn't come
up with the strategy that there were no
level let layers levers that I could
push the transformation what's going to
happen no matter what ok so my I guess
my point is with that is that you know I
was able to realize at least my analysis
is we're not going to have a lot of
reform will have some change yeah but
you can't have to use the tech to then
empower to identify well what is the
most important thing about education
it's a relationship between a teacher
and a student right how do people learn
best this is not rocket scientists
science they learn invest in small
groups yeah how can you then use the
technology to empower those two things
small classes teachers and students and
how can you create this intermediation
where you get rid of the nonce
and you shoot the cash back to the
people who are going to benefit which is
the faculty in the student so that leads
into like back to those those two things
of that and the adjunct issue the addict
issues that people can't make a living
wage as an adjunct given the
institutions of criminal zest well you
need to go to a Claire no is funny as a
faculty exactly because with the player
now you know again we brought up all
this because we're addressing concerns
about capitalist models and you know
work places and things like that with a
player know that the adjunct is able to
earn a decent wage in part because
they're getting all the payment and that
you know then it goes back to the
student who can get the education much
more cost effectively doesn't have to
take well you're you guys won't take
student loans anyway no we're on course
yeah I mean that I guess that goes one
of the things in terms of social control
and political control is the fact that
if you receive federal if you receive
federal loan money or you receive loan
money from you receive money from anyone
you're on the hook for something okay
they want something to it when it works
yes the way yes that's the way generally
exchange works today not transparent
market okay well um we're not accepting
federal student loans for a couple
different reasons one is that's a great
constraint to put your institution under
does that means that you have to make
sure things are affordable yeah okay
that you can't get things can spiral out
of control because is how they got where
the institution's gotten in the place is
really are currently yes and the other
piece is that um you know we want to be
able to innovate and we want to be able
to UM not deal with it you know
regulation is fine to search purpose it
serves its but it's important to have
regulation like you know all these these
schools that are accepting that takes
student loans like ninety percent of
their revenue is this is a student mom
okay yeah um or grant you know what's
happening with some veterans who are
coming back to the US
some breast schools are getting involved
in the level of debt it is totally
appropriate for the government to say
you can't you know like eight we're
paying the bill you can't take out the
you know you you're a debt level is too
much you're depending on that much
revenue from from from debt in terms of
your operations it's totally appropriate
for government to do to try to limit
that but what is we're trying not to
accept well we won't be accepting
student loans we will not accept me we
won't be dealing with that bureaucracy
because um we figure we can offer it
without the loaning them without the
loan and the student can work while
they're going through school yeah okay
they can also on go part time we can
change the dynamic from going to school
during this four-year intensive period
yeah to maybe making arm learning back
to kind of ate something that is kind of
fun and exciting and you do all the time
versus watching you know running the
race and then wondering what whatever
yeah we're watching the bachelor or the
bachelorette yum which is sometimes my
guilty pleasure really yeah I mean
sometimes I have others sometimes
they're fun yeah um we should probably
start answering some of the questions
that been posed so one of the first ones
that was asked is is a will Claire no
have an IRB that's a institutional
review board for human experimentation
um we are currently working on a
business model to deal with to try and
change research just like we're trying
to change the adjunct the faculty pay
piece okay in many institutions grants
on the institution takes thirty five
forty percent of the grant and the
faculty member gets 60 yeah okay or it's
even worse in some places believe it or
not um IRB is institutional review
boards to review research are very very
important um I have you know we're a
global organization so we're going to
have to look at you know global
standards
arm for IRB but sure if you're going to
be performing some kind of research
publishing publishing something we're
gonna have an IRB I'd welcome anyone who
armed with that background to start to
contact me at skiff at a planar comm
check out the wiki and then let's figure
out the structure um we don't want to
get into a situation where we're doing
things like what facebook was up to I'm
active you know yeah manipulation of
people's opinions well people's
existence is willy nilly I mean that
that for me that experiment you know
crosses a boundary i don't think that
experiment the facebook was dealing with
was unethical and we talked about it on
a bunch of our hangouts about whether we
were going to leave we haven't gotten
enough feedback in the whole thing with
match com yeah you know in present day I
mean that's not that's not okay in my
book that's not okay so you know we
don't want that stuff to go on in order
organization for those because they're
not educational app apparently Facebook
me help well as big as it it you know
well it's good i didn't just kind if
just because you don't f toward well you
call the old utterly what doesn't sure
but just because I mean it's a kind of a
no-brainer for me if I was Zuckerberg
okay I would be kind of number one
apologizing but if you know you
shouldn't have signed off on so that's a
thought okay the trouble is some of the
corporations that do have backwards they
can they can turn into just rubber strip
secondly is too far yeah well so what
are their questions have we have we got
spinney studies done in online courses
require for interaction with instructor
facilitation absolutely so let's talk
about that actually that's a that's
something that we were talking about
earlier today I think that some people
get into online teaching because they
think this is going to be easy doing a
correspondence course I'm not a with
these students but in order for it to be
a UH in order for learning
place which is what the worst about you
know in any in any course it more out of
an online instructor you know this I
know this from from teaching online you
design things for students and try to
get the resources as possible but you're
on a toilet all the time well this
because it's asynchronous you're on the
hook all time I think the difference is
that really important yeah in the past
was being the door hey you had to enter
the class bad that person was okay the
lecture I mean yeah I know but we've all
attended those classes where we walk I
mean good god lord help us okay deliver
us from this professor yeah um because
again behind the dunkin see when the
online learning well in today since it
whether it's on canvas or something it's
not yellow door you can record look I
think teaching there's too much of this
and it's you know it supported by the
traditional institutions of higher Eddie
there's this real nice division they
want to create between there's online
learning online teaching yeah and then
there's real teaching that we've been in
the classroom at ok and teachings
teaching you're just you know I try to
always think of I'm just using that
using the skills my class mm-hmm that I
teach physically ok has um all the
components of my on you know of the
online course the difference is that
students can work asynchronously the
difference is that i can pull in
simulations ok in some ways I think that
the opportunity for real learning and
interaction and engagement is higher in
the online platform then there is in the
traditional edify for me because of my
students now that enter my class can be
from anywhere on the planet so you
instantly have a you know you can have
an incredible diversity of opinions of
background yeah um you can do much more
sophisticated things in terms of again
on simulations and access different you
know
data and projects and the experience can
be Richard what you're missing is the
nonverbal cues yeah it happened in the
classroom and the sum of that can be
supplied though over video I mean right
out of the spatiality no you don't see
the sweat you know you can't employ them
if it's good enough yeah but you don't
see them you know like you can enter a
room you can sense whether you know when
you're up in front of the board and
you're teaching yeah you know when
you've lost your audience you know when
you've lost the students and you say wow
this lecture really stinks would let me
switch it yeah but but that's what we've
got to empower that's what we've got to
empowers that you know you know what um
you can know what is happening I think
you know I think that just by having
they actually focus on course design
when you're in the online environment
there's a lot of things you can sort of
take for granted in a face-to-face class
that you cannot take for granted yeah
you either think about how you're going
to supply it or it doesn't get supply
yep you know because the students aren't
going to build it into canvas yeah it's
not it's up to us to do that although
there are there are ways you can get I
mean the best learning the best classes
that I've taught have been where I
become a facilitator and the students
are learning innovating I've given to
the tools to learn and innovate
themselves yeah and they basically
produce more information and learn in
ways in which I can't keep track of and
assess it kind of like something
something magical happens and there's a
there's an explosion yeah okay and
you're you're just barely in charge
kinda it's like skateboarding down a big
help no scheme yeah you know going for
that you know that cool run you know or
something along that line a hunter storm
yeah let's do we have any other
questions coming up just thinking a bit
of produce let's see so no face
oak wood block eat nope Facebook was
just thinking of Eden practice teaching
students to justify about the paperwork
they may deal with the Faculty's
paperwork for Russian yeah well you know
um we're keeping the classes small you
know again 25 and under 20 and under I
think it's a great place to start with
you know there is going to be a lot more
documentation on the portfolio ok i am
skills piece however since the classes
are smaller that may be easier to deal
with then you have a class of 200 Oh the
difference is going to be though that
you know that you're getting I mean
you're getting the revenue ok you're
getting the bulk of the of the financial
payment yeah so it incentivizes if
you're right it's your classroom you
won't it forever I thong as you get good
so if somebody who's gone through yeah
it's close to having finished design use
its first class you know pitch to class
and all that I can say that to to you
know there is some hoop jumping involved
of course in a pitch in the class but
it's a crook that's the sort of stuff
that has to happen you have to have some
clear learning outcomes that we can in
fact give some sort of criteria for
because one of the things is you're
designing the class your assignments are
going to have rubrics and the rubrics
are going to have to have you know clear
criteria because otherwise you know i
think it's doing a disservice as
students not to have rubrics these days
for it for a long things and then you
know what else is required as far as
paperwork I mean the syllabus which you
know that any instructor should be
putting a lot of thought into the design
and so this anyway so that's not really
that's not something owner is that's
that's the opportunity to decide how
your class is going to be structured and
to give the students though the basic
Constitution you know I'm class well
then it goes back to the switch I don't
think paperwork is necessarily onerous
if you own the paper meaning
on por vivir a good reason yeah I mean
meaning that the IP is owned by faculty
yeah okay you own your class okay that
in itself is a revolutionary concept
yeah okay um and you can teach not based
on whether you've been assigned
particular students okay but you can
teach so long as your reviews are good
and you can attract students to your
class so the politics piece that you
have to plan me how many of us have you
know scrambled in talking to the chair
oh pretty please can I please have that
section on yeah fill in the blank and
you don't have to do that you know
there's going to be the marketing there
is going to be helped with for us in a
player know with on getting the word out
to potential students yeah and that's
really really important but um I think
we you know we're trying to eliminate as
much of that the the nonsense is
possible um so we'll see you know so
yeah um yeah what any more questions
then do we have anything I want you to
Oh what are like one for me was asking
if a player offers a tuition African
dictator if an employer off / situation
Benedict can they play head to a planner
arm we can accept the payment from
anyone I think what has to happen is the
student why you know the student should
contact should contact me directly and
then let's figure out how we're going to
deal with that a lot of place but I
don't see I don't see where there's a
problem I don't see that being a problem
at all okay those another question he
asked me if you recommended instructors
include local or virtually boasted meals
for students to face-to-face discussions
have you in so the question is here at
man have you have we recommended it's
that instructors hold face-to-face
meetups in person or or virtually I
think people should have meetups I think
people should engage virtually yes but I
on but I actually
member it put your students at a
disadvantage in a class where they're
spread out all over the place for some
of them to be meeting the instructor
face to face while others don't have
that opportunity I mean that the holiday
well I think there's two I think there's
a bunch of different issues with the
with the face to face me up I think that
you got to remember that your your
students are going to be from all over
the planet yeah and the time you're the
biggest issues are going to be
scheduling in times when you're all
meeting together for a discussion
virtually on if you want to do that the
nice thing about canvases you can have a
synchronous face-to-face discussions
okay well you're recording different
different answers I also think I'm you
know uh so I don't want to be too
prescriptive again I am that's why
that's a good thing that the talking Oh
going back to this you know the whole
things I've got this this thing going
why don't you want to be to perspective
there may be occasions where it is
completely appropriate and a great idea
to have had students be meeting
physically um you know maybe some are
meeting physically with an instructor
but but others are away like for example
let's say I was teaching a coursing um I
use this exemplar Lee or tropical
biology and there were a few people who
are taking the class and near where i
was living in ecuador and we wanted to
go through a cloud force with google
glass and identify various species and
and we could broadcast that to the rest
of our class and that would be that
would be a thing that would be very very
appropriate there you're using the work
of the students who are physically able
to be there as something to benefit the
others sure that's the key thing well
but you know what again i just came up
it took me two seconds to say well any
that rule might not you know the
disadvantage that you said actually I
turned it into an event yeah so I don't
really you know it's we have to trust
our professionals okay faculty members
are the treasure of an institution okay
what we have to
is transparency okay in terms of
operations and what is expected yeah and
so on you know to quote the immortal
movie spinal tap which no one under the
age of 30 is seen but it's a good move
in efficiency but should see there's a
fine line between stupid and clever okay
so um I don't like having a ton of um
you know we may have to have a ton of
you know I hope we don't we may have to
have certain protocols or guidelines but
we're going to discuss those as a
community I'm going to arrive at that
and i'm going to constantly search for
the way in which that rule is not good I
mean we basically the relationships you
know to prevent yeah everything's
written out in the faculty and student
contract until we need to modify that
that's what we're going to go by on the
course included an hour of officer that
I will be in the channel yeah on the
court head well that's that's really
wrong a pat was saying who's in the room
with us right now she was saying that on
the course outline she includes a an
hour worth of face-to-face office time
now that's really going to be that is
important but the hour is interesting
remember since you've got students
potentially all over the world the
office hours that you do during the week
are going to have to vary yeah you may
have to have some early early in the
morning for you which are going to be
late at night on you know middle of the
day for your students and vice versa so
the you know realize start thinking the
paradigm shift though there anywhere
world so you have to design and create
flexibility so that that people can
engage in when they need to um but I
also you know yeah I'm thinking still
spinal to happen about the am so turned
up to 11 this it ends up to a live oh
that's probably my favorite part there's
no reason why they can't turn up to love
you get out by I always like it's a fine
line between stupid and clever it's very
know this will be turned into Daniel
might be typing in
the answers cassis a certain yeah well
there you go um we should probably start
bringing this to close so hopefully wait
what we don't want to go for another
hour okay hopefully this is this is
addressed a lot of the concerns that
people have some people now have a
clearer idea of what you know what the
plural model is and how it differs from
some of the other educational models out
there what motivated Rob's GiftA to
start it and the staff to get involved
and then people like me to want to
become instructors i'll let you have the
last word um you know I really
appreciate your coming up and staying at
the house and dealing with me for the
last time for days I mean for four days
and thanks to everyone who's listening
in ensuring the videos I mean this is
this is a most important work that that
I've been involved in um and you know
the time has come to just to shake
things up because what's working what's
happening right now and in high red both
nationally in the US and globally is
just not okay and we need to we need to
change it and the only way we change it
is by on up ending the model that's
perfect see you later